in Peters fiddler and also one of our
colleagues doing a lot of commentary of
course but now showing your skills at
the board Peter described today it's
certainly another fascinating day with
fascinating position well you keep on
telling me I should stop whining but
today today I really felt like I was not
in control whatsoever and I'm very lucky
I think this still being it somehow I
had a bad position I think in the first
rapid second rapid the the you know the
the less said about the second rapid the
better I just I just played that game
slowly and poorly and that's a not a
good combination against hikaru and I'm
still a flawed because I'm somehow
winning the Blitz which is frankly
bizarre stunning given how good yeah it
really is kind of bizarre to me that
this is happening but this is this is
how I'm still still in the match in fact
you said you were afraid of yeah yeah I
thought I thought my shot should be the
rapid games because the Blitz games you
know on paper I I should be a huge dog
but so far I'm surviving by somehow
winning and and once again some of the
positions I won in blitz were really
poor and I suspect the one I won today
was also not not that stellar he
probably wasn't lost but I I felt like I
was worse almost straight out of the
opening and yeah I mean the one thing to
be to be happy about is I'm not giving
up I'm fighting and you know looking for
chances and exploiting the chances when
they when they come but I I will have to
play better tomorrow what are you
learning about chess from playing these
games
it's it's very confusing and once again
I feel like we're not really getting to
the bottom of these things and for
instance we
me and Gary today I think we were very
wrong about our approach to 1e for both
as a move that we could have tried and
as a move that a reply needs to be made
to with black and what I did was wrong I
felt and what what Gary did was also at
least the first try was was not ideal
and it's very very interesting to find
the you know the hidden dynamics and the
hidden geometries like in particular
this starting position the the fact that
after e4 black has to play seeks with
the intention of playing d5 and
attacking the central pawn if white
let's say goes he forty-six he forty
sixty four apparently b5 black is
already like seriously better yeah and
some of the guys actually spotted this
idea they told us we were just waiting
for the interviewer disgusting kind of
the the day with the other with the
other players and some of the the teams
so to speak actually spotted this idea
and knew that he forty six is a correct
apply and it feels like it's it's a it's
very interesting just how much unusual
ideas you can find and we we did find
some but they where I felt somewhat rare
less relevant objectively to what this
position is about I think this is a very
very interesting position probably the
most interesting we've had so far in my
opinion and I personally haven't done it
any justice well you are still in this
match and the blitz
if the blitz has been any consolation
for you the fact that you have been
doing well you've got eight blitz games
coming up yes tomorrow
that would've been a nightmare maybe a
few of days ago for you but now and it's
also I think it's gonna be a fun day and
I'm slightly sort of more intuitive take
them then the three we we had because
there will be less time to to try and
figure something out and you know now
that we've established that I'm not
really very good at figuring things out
from from starting positions I think
just sort of putting me in behind the
pieces and telling me to play is maybe
the the best approach and this is what
tomorrow will be like so we'll see and
also adjusting to the meta so to speak
and kind of trying to to catch some
things on the fly some things that are
happening in in the other matches is
it's probably an interesting part of it
in particular tomorrow when you really
won't have too much time between games
to to do any of your own work so trying
to catch some ideas that are happening
around you might be might be an
interesting sub story all right well be
looking forward to your match extremely
competitive one good luck thank you
Peter